Nicole why did you decide to apply for
TV writing programs
I had been trying on my own for many
many years to break into the business
and I had been lucky enough to have some
writers who were already in the field
read me and encourage me but nobody was
really able to help me get
representation or do any of that stuff
you have to do to finally break through
and to the writing programs were sort of
the best option for somebody trying to
get their foot in the door and I applied
to all of them I had varying success in
all of them I had no luck at Warner
Brothers I have never been able to move
the needle in the Warner Brothers
writing program I made the finals at
Disney twice but then didn't make the
last cut
uh and you know I had applied to all of
them multiple times and when I finally
applied to the CBS writers program
and got in it was really a case of I I
was beating my head against the wall
right and I was just like how much more
of this can I do and I had a backup plan
in progress I had started a cookie
business and I was like taking orders
online and I was baking in a kitchen
that used to be in Pasadena but sadly is
no longer there but you could rent a
commercial kitchen space by the hour so
like I was getting up and running and
doing all this stuff with that and I had
a conversation with myself where I was
like well you're gonna always write it's
not like you're gonna quit writing but I
was just like I can't keep doing this I
can't keep applying to these fellowships
and all those sorts of things and what
happened basically was I went to my day
job
and my boss yelled at me for caring too
much about how I did my job
and it was just so antithetical to how I
had been brought up by my very like
military Catholic black parents to like
do your best at everything and always
over perform and do all those things and
I couldn't make sense of it and I came
home and I cried myself asleep basically
because I was just like well I don't
want to do this either like this is
terrible
and I woke up in the morning and I
thought you know try one more time like
is there anything you can still apply to
just try and for the first time in the
history of the CBS writers program
except for when the pandemic happened
they had delayed the application period
by one month and I had two days to get a
script in and because my mentors were
always making me right I had a script
ready to go and I put it in the mail and
I got it postmarked and next thing I
knew I was in the program
wow so many questions with that first
off just curious what was that script
it was a spec episode of The Closer
which was one of my favorite shows and
you know it was funny because a lot of
people had said to me like I don't know
if you should spec that because nobody
in the business reads that you know
watches this show and I was like I'm
gonna write a show that I know I can
write
just balls out like with all the passion
all the joy I can put into it and I love
this show and so that's the script I'm
gonna write
and I had multiple people tell me once
it got into the you know the writing
program circuit and people were reading
it that they don't watch the show but
they loved this story and they had to
see how it ended
and so that's always my advice to Young
Writers now it's like write the spec
that you of a show you love whether you
think people watch it or not because
good writing leaps off the page
and I do think Young Writers should
still be writing specs it is my advice
to them one just have one for a show you
love because there are showrunners who
will not staff
staff writers unless they see a spec
it's not common anymore but they're
there's a growing movement among
showrunners to get back to that because
writing a Specs group of Television is
literally the job you're trying to get
you have to write someone else's show in
their voice in the exact format that
they like
and you have to get as close to it as
you can so that's the job so why not
practice it before you get the job
were they telling you to write other
things that were quote unquote popular
at the time
there were definitely other shows that
were more popular I think a lot of
people were writing you know The Walking
Dead
um there were there were lots of shows
and I typically as a TV fan will love
one or two of the really popular things
but I tend to love more bread and butter
shows like I was a huge Castle fan I was
a huge fan of Person of Interest in
elementary and like those were the shows
that I wanted to spend my time on and
less so you know the walking dead or Mad
Men and because they just were not my
they were not the kind of shows I get
joy from and so people were like well
you have to write you know you have to
write a more serious drama and I was
like do I though like I feel like I
don't and so I'm really glad I stuck to
my guns because it worked out
um what most people tell Young Writers
now is to be writing pilots and they
should be absolutely be writing their
own Original Stories but a really great
pilot isn't proof to me that you can
write my TV show so that's why I always
tell people they should still have a
spec around for a current show that's
airing just in case someone asks for it
and to show that they really care about
because that's going to show yes right I
think especially because right when what
was happening when I broke in was
everyone was specking the same shows
so if you could stand out somehow by
having to show that they were not used
to reading right away you were like oh
well this is a different show this isn't
the 17th madman's back I'm getting this
what is this closer spec and so it is
another way to stand out if you're not
doing these the shows that everybody
else is doing
were you able to go back to that job and
give your two weeks
so interestingly what happened with that
job I uh continued doing it while I was
doing the CBS program
um because you know it's not a paid
program and then so I had to keep paying
my bills and I also continued to do it
during writers on the verge which I did
after the CBS program and that was about
the time that I was like you know what
even if I have to take a job you know
cleaning houses or doing whatever I can
do hard work I can work as hard as other
people who are paying their bills I
can't do this job anymore
and I put my notice in and two weeks
later I got my first staff writing job
so I always tell people I feel like the
universe was like well she means it this
time
so we better help her out
wow what a great story and the cookie
business the cookie business went away
because I was too busy uh writing
however the baking did not go away so my
writer's rooms are always very happy
they get lots of cookies everyone in my
life likes to get baked goods for
Christmas so you know it's it the baking
part still happens just not the business
part
how many TV writing programs can you
name there is the ABC Disney fellowship
and some of them have tweaked their name
slightly before I say them all so trust
me when you look them up it might be
boarded a little bit different but ABC
Disney's Fellowship
NBC's uh I
I can't remember what they're calling it
now but they they did reenact their
writing program so just look for NBC TV
writing program and you'll find it uh
the now Viacom writers mentoring program
which is the CBS program now
there is
um
oh goodness the Warner Brothers program
is still there there have been
fellowships and I'm not as wired into
these but I know for a while
um uh
Sundance was doing one I believe that
was a like TV incubator for new writers
um there have been other like uh
oh I'm gonna forget the name of their
production company Ron Howard's company
imagine has done their own writing
program where they've encouraged writers
to submit and have done some stuff so
it's really if you if you go look up
writing programs there are a lot of
opportunities now that didn't exist I'm
currently a mentor and a newer one it's
called mentorship matters we just
finished our application period on the
26th and we got 800 applications
so we'll you know our readers are going
through that process now of reading
everything and sort of narrowing the
field
um but that one started uh some
wonderful people
um Rael Tucker Gianna Sobel and Carol
kirschner all got together during the
pandemic sort of post uh George Floyd's
murder and decided like what what can we
do like we're full of anger and the
world is crazy what can we do and they
came up with the idea for this program
where we give people who haven't been
assistants haven't had a chance to
Access Hollywood yet the opportunity to
be read and be mentored and see if they
can break through
how many writers get into these programs
a year not just the ones that you put in
for but like all of them in general you
know it'd be hard to say I mean they all
the numbers vary like
the CBS program usually takes anywhere
from five to eight people I believe
um you know I think we had eight people
in my NBC class I think Disney usually
takes 10. so it's sort of I mean
mentorship matters we had more than that
because as many mentors as we had
because each Mentor got one writer so we
had
I want to say
35-ish mentors so we all had a mentee so
it really sort of depends on what the
program can accommodate and so for
mentorship matters you said 800
just for the the phrase at the first
year that it's we finished the first
year so this is going to be for year
number two starting in the fall
800 and this is um globally
it's yeah I think it was if I remember
correctly anyone could apply but you had
to be able to be
um in the U.S to do the program because
they there are like panels that have to
occur and there's Staffing opportunities
part of what we do in that program is
use our Network to help our mentees so
introducing them to reps to show Runners
to other writers that they can connect
with and you kind of need to be in the
vicinity to do that even though we have
zoom now it's easier I think so I do
think there's a U.S requirement but I
can't remember entirely
do you have to pay to be in the program
or do they pay you
most of the programs don't pay but you
do not have to pay to be in them they
are
investment programs that the networks
have in the Studios have come up with to
try to to grow homegrown Talent with an
angle on diversity and inclusion so the
ABC Disney program has historically been
the only one that pays its writers and
they pay like I believe it's like fifty
thousand dollars a year
while you're in it but it does mean and
you have a greater chance of Staffing
because they can put you out to the
entire ABC Disney family right for
Staffing opportunities but it does mean
you get paid that salary you're not
getting paid a staff writer salary
most of the other programs what they do
is the studio has money set aside so if
for instance when I got my job on
Ironside the studio supplemented my
salary so it didn't come out of the show
budget and that's how they try to
encourage people to give writers like me
an opportunity and then if you prove
yourself you get to stay on regardless
and they'll you know you have to make
the showrunner be willing to pay for you
I do think there's a movement now to
start adjusting that a little bit
because what we've been finding is that
showrunners will use the free writer not
all some let me make sure that's clear
some showrunners will use the free rider
for as long as the studio will pay for
them and then not bring them back and so
the studios are now looking at how can
they make it an encouraging factor to
keep the writers going forward so
they're looking at how they can change
that payment system a little bit to you
know to encourage retention
what are you learning inside of these
programs
they all are structured a little bit
different but I would say in general the
big takeaways or first of all you're
going to write a new piece of material
and you're going to do it with
professional mentorship so this is going
to be getting notes from people who give
studio and network notes to real
professional writers all the time right
so it's a little bit different than your
writer's group giving you notes or your
friends and it gives you a sense of what
that's like when you're on staff when
you're developing to get notes from
those kind of professionals so hopefully
you have a great new piece of material
to help you secure representation and to
go out for Staffing the programs will
also prep you for Staffing in terms of
Executives coming in and meeting with
you and liking you so they'll consider
sending your name to their showrunners
that they're working with who are
looking for you know new writers also
you get practice in how to handle
meetings with showrunners how to go
through a general meeting because like I
always tell people when I got in the CBS
program I would have treated a
showrunner meeting like a regular job
interview because I had no idea what it
was it is very much not that it is
really just go in and have a
conversation with someone
because the truth of a meeting a general
meeting or a showrunner meeting
is that you're they already like your
writing that's how you got in the room
so now you're there to show who you are
to be your best self
to make them laugh if you're doing a
comedy to tell interesting stories if
you're doing a drama that's you know
tied to your experience whatever it is
and show them that basically you're a
nice normal person you're not going to
make their life harder and they wouldn't
mind being in a room with you for 10 12
hours a day
and that's half the trick is just being
able to go in and be relaxed and you
know do those meetings
and so that's a big element of almost
every program is teaching you how to
handle that that prep and how to get
ready for those meetings
what are the key benefits that TV
writing programs offer
I mean first of all it's that that
experience of meeting some Executives
meeting some managers to get practice
for how to do those kind of meetings and
also introductions right I got my first
agent through an introduction from one
of the programs I got my manager through
an introduction from one of the programs
so that helps you find representation if
you don't have it
I met tons and tons of Executives some
of whom have become close friends over
the years from that those writing
programs
so you have that connection base that
you start to build out it gives you a
cohort of writers to be your support
system as you build your career because
you need people to you know if something
crazy happens in the room you need
someone to be like on you know on your
break texting going what is
craziness that just happened is it just
me or is
and they can be like no that's crazy
just remember take a deep breath it's
all gonna be fun
um or to get advice on things when
you're you know you're stuck on a story
point and you're scared to go to the
showrunner and you can have a friend
who's like no it's better go ask the
showrunner before you make a mistake in
the script like do it those kind of
things
and then it's also just the the
community that you start to build
I hate networking it's like one of my
least favorite words
I used to hate when they would be like
we're having a writer's mixer and you
know I would have to go and a full
disclosure I still hate the idea of them
what has happened over the years though
is that I would force myself to go I
would be like just go for an hour just
go for one hour and then talk to a few
people and you can leave and because I
have done that because the writing
program so often co-mingle and have
crossover you develop this whole network
of people that you are friendly with and
who you like and who are interesting to
talk to
and you build this whole community so
when one of my friends becomes a
showrunner and it's like I need a great
bipoc mid-level writer who do you know
we all can respond to that because they
just reach out to their people and then
we all are like oh this person this
person's great I'll have I'll get a
script and send it to you and we can
support each other and help each other
as we all grow through our careers so
that's honestly one of the most valuable
things that comes out of it and you're
kind of with them for life so to speak a
little bit yeah you know it's like the
my class of
uh from CBS and from NBC we're all still
in touch we're all still very close we
you know celebrate each other's wins we
commiserate over our losses it's it's
you know it's your little TV family that
you build and then as you build your
career every room you go to you're going
to meet people who you want to know for
the rest of your life you know it won't
be everyone but there's going to be
people in every room that you're like
now you are stuck with me
hahaha
do you think you would have broken into
television had you not gone through one
of these programs
I don't think I would have to be honest
I think I had tried everything I could
think of outside of the programs
and the one thing I had not been able to
do was work as an assistant in
television and because I put myself
through undergrad and graduate school
and had very Hefty student loans I just
couldn't afford to I did not have the
support system to allow me to make what
assistants make and then also keep a
roof over my head and so that was just
never going to be a thing I could do
and even when I tried to do it people
were like you have a master's degree you
cannot be a PA and I was like no no I
can I really can't
trust me I will make it work and they
were like no we're not gonna we don't
believe you so that opportunity wasn't
there and I think were it not for the
programs I'm not sure how I would have
ever made it happen I mean I would have
continued to write certainly
um would it have been enough to finally
get a door to open I don't know
had you been tempted to leave your
master's degree or even your bachelor's
off of resume so there's some survival
jobs here in La they pay some pretty
good wages do you think they felt you
were overqualified and it scared them
away yeah
yeah absolutely and and for me like you
know the job that I was doing the day
job as much as I hated it it allowed me
to survive and it allowed me to you know
pay all my bills and pay all my loans
and keep a roof over my head and so it
was just like look this is the way it's
gonna be and
you know it could have there it was that
push-pull of yes I could have taken the
Master's Degree off my resume but so
much of what I had learned about how the
business worked I had learned because of
that master's program because this was
before the writing fellowships right so
I was also cutting down the sense of
experience I had so it was like you know
I'm just gonna try it and they'll say
yes or they'll say no and they always
said no but I'm still here anyway
what advice do you have to other writers
who are considering these kinds of
programs
my biggest advice is you know when
you're when you're thinking about what
to submit whether it's a spec or a pilot
I think CBS might be the only program
left or Viacom might be the only program
left that's requiring specs much to my
dismay but whatever it is you're
submitting
if you were going to be identified by
one piece of writing
that's the script you submit because you
only really have that one shot and then
the next year if you didn't get into any
of them you have to have the next script
that is the script that you would want
to represent you so that's why I say you
always have to be writing because you
always need new material even once you
start your career people will have read
the two samples that you broke in with
and so you have to have new samples to
send out places so you know always be
writing and when you get to the points
in those applications where they
ask you you know there's always either
essay questions or a video element and
it's like you know what do you have to
contribute to a writer's room
really think about what your life
uniquely offers to your storytelling
it's not about how much you love TV it's
not about how you've dreamed of being a
writer since you were a kid it's about I
have gone through X Y and Z in my life
and not trauma just experiences you've
been through it can be that you you
lived in 17 places because your dad was
in the military or that you love to hike
and you've hiked seven of the craziest
places in the world to hike whatever it
is that's special about you you want to
bring out in those questions and that
response because that's the stuff that
people are looking for it's like what's
the special sauce you bring into the
room because you know almost everyone
and I do say almost because not a
blanket statement almost everyone who
wants to be a TV writer loves TV so it's
like why you and that's the question
you're really answering
what were you doing the first six months
before you were accepted into the TV
writing program
I was working on my baking business I
had developed a a brochure of all like
the different types of special things
that I could do and I was gonna go out
to some wedding fairs and try to drum up
business doing favors for weddings and I
was in fact at the kitchen baking all
day to go to a food show came home and
got the email saying congratulations
you're a semi-finalist for the CBS
writers program please call and schedule
your personal interview
so it was really like a crazy like the
universe was like she's too good at the
cookie thing we gotta we gotta pivot
back and put her where she belongs
and so you rented a kitchen because
that's how you could get it sort of
permitted to to yeah yeah was um long
before there was any thought of you know
allowing people in L.A County to bake
from home or cook from home to sell it
and so
um you know Pasadena has its own
licensing requirements and all that so I
had to do all the research to figure all
that stuff out had to figure out how to
get the right insurance I mean it was a
lot but uh you know I toughed it out and
figured it out and got my business up
and running and then
Hollywood was like no change of plans
how many TV show scripts and Pilots had
you written before you were hired
oh goodness I think I have this
officially written down somewhere I want
to say that I had written 12 specs
and I had
four Pilots
and the last spec I wrote was for Person
of Interest and I finished it a few
weeks before I got my first TV writing
job so it turned out to be the last one
I ever had to write and how long like
how many pages are let's say a normal
spec most specs you want to I mean most
TV scripts in general especially back
then range anywhere from 52 to 60 Pages
you really want to try not to go over 60
because it's big ask on the reading time
nowadays if you're on staff some shows
come in much shorter our scripts on
swatter 46 pages so you have to be
really you know very specific about the
word choice you can get it all in but
also keep it to a minimum
um but yeah so anywhere from like 52 if
it's a drama script if it's a comedy
script it's usually right around 30-ish
pages
what key factors uh played a part in you
being hired
I think one of the big ones was my life
experience so I broke into television
working in cop shows and I had put
myself through my undergraduate years
working as a police dispatcher and I
would work graveyard shifts and then I
would get off at 7 45 in the morning
drive to school go to school all day
come home and sleep go back to work and
thankfully I was allowed to do homework
at my desk when nothing was happening so
that's the only way I got through it and
that experience was always appealing to
people who make those kind of shows and
in broadcast television as we know those
shows are very prevalent and you know I
could talk about things that were real
and that pertain to those stories and so
that was a big calling card for me was
being able to to bring that real life
professional experience in
um it was also important that I was a
black woman that I could speak to
matters of you know inequity for our
characters that we were writing that I
could talk about what it's like to be a
black woman who's the only black
employee in a play you know that I could
talk about those things and I was
willing to share those stories in the
room
um and then you know that I was prepared
that I had
written and written and written and
written and had built my muscle to the
point that someone was like okay she's
ready to do at least the basic part of
this job
because you will only get stronger and
get better as you continue your career
but you have to there's there's such a
line between
writing a decent script and writing a
professional script and it's really
about the the passion and the fluidity
that you can put on the page that it
starts to feel a little cinematic that
they can picture it when they read it
and it's not just you know she walks to
the door it's like you know she walks to
the door and it dwarfs her and it's like
you're conveying a real image with it so
you learn all that by writing and by
sharing your work with other writers the
biggest mistake that I think newer
writers make is wanting to hold other
scripts really close and not let other
people read them but you only get better
when other people read it and say to you
you know I love this idea and this
character is great I got a little
confused through here because I wasn't
quite sure why the character was doing
this or why we went to this place
suddenly and you take those notes and
you go back and make it better
because that is TV writing that is the
rest of your life if you want to write
TV as people will give you notes you
will go make a changes you will turn it
back in even if you're the showrunner
the studio and the network get to give
you notes so you will take their notes
you will you know unless you're one of
those writers who declares you never
take notes uh but I do not know many of
those you know that existed yeah okay
yes yes there are there are some of them
and I'm like okay you do you but uh I
take I you know I take good notes I take
good notes sometimes there are good
notes
what do you think is more common for a
new writer in a TV room to want to hold
back some of their work or want to hold
back their personal experience
and maybe not speak to what their life
was because they don't want to offend
other people in the room or make them
uncomfortable
yeah I think that they're kind of part
and parcel of the same thing I think new
writers in our writer's room have to
learn that balance of when do I speak
when do I not speak and some of it's
just literally the timing of it right
figuring out your window to say the
thing you want to say how to do it
without cutting off another writer how
to do it without crapping on somebody
else's pitch even if you don't like it
right but to be able to be like hey that
might work also what if we did Bloody
blah so that you're not you know side
swiping them you're just saying here's
another idea and internally you're like
because I don't like that idea
or you're being additive or you're
inspired by what someone said and you're
like oh my God I love that also could we
add this to it and then maybe it gets
better or maybe your suggestion gets
pushed to the side but you made your
suggestion and a lot of new writers are
very intimidated when they get to the
writer's room and it's a lot especially
if you are say on a broadcast show with
like 10 other writers
I'd estimate eight of those writers are
pretty solidly experienced and so it's
just Fast and Furious of story pitches
and this and that and what if we did
this and great let's have the character
move here and let's use this setting and
it starts to be overwhelming and so
the advice that I was given that I pass
on to all new writers is try to say
something you think is of value in the
morning and something of value after
lunch
in the beginning that's all anybody's
going to expect of you in fact they will
be real impressed that they got those
two things because you're a staff writer
and those people all understand that
they all know this is new to you they
all know you're trying to find your
footing
so you don't have to come in and sit
there in silence unless you have a
showrunner who's told you that staff
writers are not supposed to speak and it
does happen but in most rooms you're so
scared to speak that that's why you're
not speaking and so you need to find
your voice and speak you also need to be
careful not to try to dominate the
conversation and take over you need to
pick up on the social cues of when the
share Runners like yeah I don't I don't
know about that and stop talking and let
someone else pitch something you may
come back to your idea but if you keep
pushing it's going to cause some
friction in the room so it's it's really
learning that is is the first several
weeks for any staff writer is trying to
figure out how this all works and when
do I speak and when do I pull back I'm a
big proponent of having a notebook in
front of you
because as you have an idea you can
write it down
and if someone else is still talking a
you won't forget it and B because you
have it writing down you're not panicked
about getting it out and if someone else
pitches the same idea before you do at
least you can take comfort in the fact
that you were on the right track
but it's also a lesson in right your
idea was right so you can pitch it it's
fine and take the chance and Pitch it
in terms of the personal stories I think
good writer's rooms Foster an
environment where writers feel safe to
share their stories
and by good writers rooms I mean safe
writers rooms places where the
showrunner has said up front
this is not a place where we bully each
other this is not a place where I'm
going to tolerate that kind of behavior
everybody's opinion here matters at the
end of the day I'm going to decide what
we're doing so you don't even need to
fight about it because it's so to me and
that allows people to feel safe saying
you know I did have this experience when
I was a kid where like I got lost for a
day and my parents like because that's a
vulnerable thing to talk about right but
it may help the story
and you want your writers to feel safe
to help build the best story
toxic rooms
rooms where showrunners yell and scream
at each other nobody in that room is
giving their best nobody is telling
their best stories because they don't
feel safe
and so to respond to that kind of
behavior everybody pulls back a little
bit and it's and you should because you
need to protect yourself in that
environment
how much does your acceptance of Fate
factor into your writing career
for me I am a firm believer that I have
always ended up where I was supposed to
and you know I'm sure there are people
who are like well you know you just want
to believe that because it's it makes it
easier when stuff doesn't go your way
yes it does it does make it easier but I
also think it's true so a perfect
example of this is after I finished
writers on the verge
I I probably did
somewhere around 30 meetings that year
which is a lot my agent and my manager
had me on General after General after
General and I had four share render
meetings
and for those jobs literally every
single one was it's between you and one
other person
and one other person got all the jobs
and two of those people were my friends
so I could have chosen to be sad about
it or I could be happy for my friends
and I'd be sad for myself for a day I
gave myself a day to cry it out
and then I had to be like what what's
next what do I do next and so what I did
next was write the pilot that got me my
first job
and I had I didn't know that at the time
I was just like okay I'm gonna go write
this thing that I want to write and I
entered a pilot in the Austin film
festival and made it to the semifinals
and got to go to Austin for the first
time and it was just like what can I do
that's positive for my career what
happened later was that most of those
jobs I heard stories about them that
made me very grateful that they were not
my jobs
and then I got hired at Ironside where
you will hear lots of stories about
writers who
go into their first room and especially
if they're A diversity hire right as I
was and it's a lot of like the diversity
writer and bad attitudes and that kind
of stuff I went into a room where my
showrunner had literally basically had
the attitude of I hired these two staff
writers because I like them and I think
they're talented all of you support them
and they did and so every writer in that
room helped me in some way taught me
something and I still am in contact with
almost all of them and you know they all
helped build me to the next level of my
career now that is not the way it is in
a lot of rooms it's the way it should
always be
but I ended up there because I needed
those people and then my next job I went
to
was this show called the legions and
it turned out that somebody I had met
tangentially through one of the writing
programs was going to be one of the
people in charge of that show and it he
came on after I had already had my
meeting so pure luck and happenstance
that we ended up there together
he knew that I was the kind of person
who worked hard so he told the other two
executive producers that basically like
Nicole's always going to be here we got
her and three weeks into the job my sure
Runner joked with them and said you know
we're all going to work for Nicole later
right
because I that's how I had been brought
up was to always be there and be ready
to do whatever needs to be done and
because I kept that work ethic even when
our show got difficult even when we had
struggles getting scripts out I always
kept that attitude and George nolfe who
was our showrunner ended up asking me to
co-write a movie with him
because of that work ethic because he
knew that he could count on me to do
what needed to be done and I wasn't
gonna like I don't know how to handle
all this he was like nope you can do
this so that's how I ended up co-writing
the banker which is my first feature
film
so you know that that all feels meant to
be to me and so and I feel like every
job I've ended up at I ended up at a job
I interviewed for my dream show
while I had an offer for another job and
the dream show was like we love her but
we think we're gonna hire someone else
so I took the other job I met one of my
best friends in life at that job so if I
had gone to my dream job would I ever
have met this person probably not but
she's so important to my life I'm just
glad that I did so that's how I look at
it I think
every place you end up is of value to
you I think even hard jobs teach you how
not to do the job right bad rooms teach
you how to never treat people how to not
let the process go off the rails they
teach you how to be Humane in the face
of adversity because it's what you wish
someone had done for you
so you hopefully take that you know and
carry it on with you so I just think you
know Embrace every experience as I'm
supposed to learn something here and you
will and then it's going to make you a
better writer and a leader a better
showrunner
what's that day like or the morning like
when you've had your I've heard you say
before you're allowed to grieve a
project that's lost or whatever but you
only give yourself the short window of
time so what's the next morning like
when it's like okay Nicole's not allowed
to feel bad anymore we're gonna get up
and how do you how do you give yourself
that pep talk what's that like it's
um you know it's very much a thing of it
really is it's like you get up I have to
walk my dog I have breakfast I have some
coffee and I'm like okay
what's the one thing you can do
that is a forward step it doesn't have
to be a lot I don't have to start a new
script today I don't have to know what
I'm going to pitch next if a development
project went away it's just like what
can you do today and sometimes it's just
reaching out to a writer friend and
being like hey can I talk to you about
this because it was rough and I just
want to talk it through with someone and
you do and then you're like okay and
then the next day you're like okay
talking to my reps what is what is the
project we should focus on next or I'm
like hey I got three books I'm gonna
read and see if any of them would make a
good pilot or whatever it is but
if you wallow in it because this
business is so much rejection that it's
just gonna debilitate you and so you
everyone has to find their way of being
able to be like oh that sucked and then
let it go because and and if you need
more than a day take more than a day but
like I can't spend more than
more than 48 hours in that place
because then it's harder for me to get
out so I I just say to myself like okay
this is your weekend to be sad and then
we have to move on
because it's all it's always like okay
what's next what's next what do I do
next because you're going to work jobs
you love and the show's going to get
canceled you're going to write a pilot
script that everyone says is amazing and
the Network's gonna not pick it up
you so it's just it's a lot of no and
you have to be able to say okay I'm
gonna do this next
should new TV writers focus on pitching
their shows to Studios and networks
so what's happening now I would say the
trend in this business is if you are a
writer who's actively Staffing
there there is a limit to your ability
to pitch most Studios contractually will
not allow you to start pitching projects
until you reach like co-producer level
so unless you already had something that
another Studio was interested in and you
can do what's called a carve out where
it's protected from your contract you
really are not developing if you're
Staffing constantly if you staffed once
and then you're having trouble finding
another job your reps are going to be
like well what do you have that we can
take out and pitch because it's a way to
keep you in the game
it's a way to get you out there meeting
people and sometimes it happens
sometimes newer writers sell shows and
they get made and that's amazing the
biggest obstacle when you are a newer
lower level writer and you sell a show
is that you do not have the skill set to
be a sure Runner
so what will generally happen unless you
are some wonderkind that they're gonna
they're gonna just decide you have all
it takes to be a share Runner is that an
experienced showrunner is going to be
attached to your show
and hopefully you will have some input
and how that choice is made hopefully
you can bring some names to the table if
there's you know producers you really
admire executive producers and show
Runners that you really like or who's
who you a friend of a friend told you
this person's like the greatest human
being and they might be available to run
it bring their name in a lot of times
the studios or the networks will already
have a list of people they want you to
consider you should be able to talk to
those people and give your input on who
you think is best and like this is the
person I think should run it with me
usually it's fine
um because you know most of the people
who get brought in to run a show for a
different Creator are on overall deals
and they're looking to help you get your
show off the ground so they can go make
their stuff they're really not invested
in taking your show over
there are however times that that
happens to pre to people and and this
town is full of those stories of you
know brilliant writer made the show and
then big dog producer basically pushed
them out the door and it happens and I
think you shouldn't let fear of that
stop you if someone's interested in
making your show and you're an
inexperienced writer you just need to
educate yourself on how to best protect
yourself
and don't try to protect yourself by
being like it's my show like you can't
tell me anything about it you have to
build that partnership because TV is a
team sport and anyone who's not
supporting the team is a problem
so you don't want to be a problem and
then lose any say in what happens to
your show that you created so it's a
tricky thing but it does happen and you
know reps will encourage Young Riders to
be writing pilots and trying to you know
get interest and even have them out
pitching but it's always with the
understanding that you will probably not
be running that show
and is that the scenario where someone
would say I I don't take notes is if
it's actually their their idea they're
the ones that came up with the show idea
the I don't take notes people are
um you know just certain showrunners of
a certain personality there was a pretty
widely publicized article where like
Taylor Sheridan says he doesn't take
notes
okay like I guess he doesn't you know
um there have been some other writers
that have sort of expressed that again I
think that's a if that's your
personality and that's how you move
through the world
then I understand that that's you're not
going to be different right in this
process you're going to try and do
exactly the thing you always do which is
like I know best so I'm going to do it
my way
I think most writers are not that person
most writers are
understand that someone else might have
an idea that's additive to what they've
written and it's very rarely even
scripts that I think are brilliant very
rarely that I'm not like oh this could
be better though like sometimes there's
just little things that sometimes you're
so close to it you can't see it and so
having other writers around you or
having a good executive say hey this
script is brilliant the one thing I
would say to you is these transitions
are a little confusing and a director's
not going to understand how you want it
done and you know the audience may not
track it so let's think about how to
rethink that that's a good note like you
need to look at that because they're
concerned about your show succeeding as
opposed to
I just don't understand magic why is
there magic in this show that's not
helpful if they've bought a magic show
but sometimes it happens
should there be a time limit let's say
for a newer writer should expect
to work five to ten years in a writer's
room before they actually think they can
go and Pitch their own show
or that's just there's no real hard and
fast rule there's no real hard and fast
rule there used to be definitely
um you know I interviewed with some
showrunners who had come up in the era
before I really came into the business
and it really used to be very like you
just don't run a show till you become a
coep on other people's shows
um and coep being the top level of
writer before you're an executive
producer
nowadays it's it's much more
free-flowing it's you know I know people
who have been
soldiers as staff writers who have sold
shows as you know uh producers which is
pretty right solid in the middle and
then also as coeps so it's kind of all
over the place now I think
what I would say is
really think about if if all you're
focused on is that you want to sell your
own show
staff as much as you can and just know
what you need to learn which is you need
to go to set and produce an episode
that's probably going to happen working
in broadcast television
more than it's ever going to happen in a
streaming situation so take a broadcast
job
and you need to know how post works and
you need to read as much as you can to
help educate you about how this all
works I um you know Carol Kirchner has a
great book that's called Hollywood game
plan that really sort of talks about the
the business side of the business
um Bethany Rooney wrote this amazing
book on directing for television that I
recommend to writers because it talks
about what everyone on set does
so you can really take in what all the
jobs are and because you get all these
words thrown at you like you know
someone's like a grip and someone said
this and someone's of that and you're
like what does all that mean I don't
know like because a lot of us didn't go
to film school so we don't know so you
get the book and you read what people do
and that'll help prepare you because
what you don't want to do is just assume
you know because you're a brilliant
writer how to do it all and then
suddenly you're a showrunner even today
actually John Wells just launched this
thing
um on his website where it's like the
show Runners corner where he's giving
out advice to people about how to do the
job because we have seen thanks to
streaming this Gap open up in skill sets
for writers because those of us who have
worked in broadcast television have
produced episodes have gone to post have
that experience but people who've like
their whole career's been on streaming
shows never been to set never allowed to
see Cuts they haven't been to post and
so there's this Gap in in the skills you
need to run a show happening for a whole
generation of writers and so there's a
lot of concern about how to fix that so
I was so pleased today to see that John
was like well here's a step here's this
foreign
does every writer need to know how to
write a pilot yes
yes it is absolutely a necessary skill
because it's how you it's your calling
card to get Executives to be interested
in you to get sure Runners to hire you
most of the time
except for those picky ones like me who
like to see a spec if you're breaking
into the business and it's ultimately
what you will be doing later in your
career because once you reach that
mid-level to upper level Point your reps
are going to want you to start
developing and developing is all about
writing pitch documents and then
hopefully selling a show and writing a
pilot so it is absolutely something
everyone should know how to do and you
know there are plenty of books out there
about how to do it
um I want to say I think cam Miller has
a really good book about writing a pilot
um Jan grisanti has all kinds of great
material about riding a pilot so you
know there's resources out there to help
you figure out how to demystify it a
little bit but it's you know if you if
you love to tell stories it's just a
specific way of telling the story
how did you learn to write a pilot
I learned how to ride a pilot first of
all by just being a huge student of
Television I there was a time when my
friends Charles Murray and Terence Paul
winter would tease me mercilessly about
how I watched every show on television
and it used to be true it is no longer
true there's too many shows I can't do
it
but I would sort of I have a list of
Pilots that like when I was writing a
new pilot and I was like oh the tone
doesn't feel quite right if it was
gritty I had a list of Pilots that I
would go watch to sort of get my brain
in that in that place not to take
anything from the pilot but just to have
the tone in my head of like right right
this is what I'm going for and then go
back to work on mine so studying
existing Pilots is incredibly valuable
and it'll get you know give you some
guide posts for how they did it what the
pacing of those Pilots were you know
different types of Pilots can have a
different Rhythm to them if you're doing
a big like fantasy show and you have to
you know launch it in the pilot what
some shows put in that pilot is going to
be very different than if you're
launching an ensemble drama full of a
bunch of characters who work in a
hospital right the the specifics of what
you need in those Pilots are very
different so I would study Pilots like
the one you want to write and get a feel
for you know where they put the ACT
breaks if it's a show that has ACT
breaks you should always be breaking
your stories with AC breaks PS even if
you're not going to have them in your
script
even if it's a streaming show break it
with act breaks because it will keep you
with a nice ebb and flow of action and
emotion in your episode unlike some
shows that you watch on streaming where
nothing happens for like 37 minutes and
then the last 10 minutes everything
happens so give yourself that break
write it like you have to do a
commercial break and it'll really help
you find some good ups and downs in your
storytelling
of those lists of pilots in the
different sort of genre or or style that
that you wanted to sort of delve into
did they age out after a while did
Things become too slow after maybe 10
years you know how as life is sped up I
would say no I think great Pilots are
always great Pilots you know some of the
ones that I still go back to like I tell
Young Writers who are asking me like
what pilot should I watch they should
always always watch the pilot of Hill
Street Blues which is the greatest show
in the history of Television I will
fight anyone who tries to say otherwise
because every show that came after it
that people want to say is the greatest
show in the history of Television only
exists because Stephen bochko was able
to pull that pilot off because it's you
know it changed the game in terms of how
television was made
um wise guy is one of the most amazing
TV Pilots I always recommend it to
people
um the Miami Vice pilot crazy like you
probably could not get away with the
Miami Vice pilot now because the two
main characters don't mean each other
for an hour but it's still worth looking
at because the character work is so
really really like interesting and you
know so much about those people by the
end of that pilot it's kind of like wow
okay
um
homicide life on the street one of the
greatest Pilots ever the character
introduction of Frank pembleton
is one of the greatest character
introductions I've ever seen like you
know everything you will ever need to
know about Frank pembleton from his
search for his car
everything you will ever need to know so
watching those really great shows even
if they're 10 20 30 years old the work
in them doesn't age out maybe the pacing
ages out maybe you know because the Hill
Street Blues was what 52 minutes and and
episodes and now it's you know 43
minutes so they're longer they can
linger more in some of the you know
silences of the characters and things
the driving scene like people really
literally driving down roads and you're
like no nobody has time for that anymore
but the character work the dialogue work
the ideas in the shows the way they
execute things that never ages out great
Pilots never age out in that way
what about watching Bad Pilots as
another way to teach yourself bad Pilots
is also good I mean bad Pilots is
subjective I think even more so than
great Pilots because I think right you
could Google like Alan steppenwald
telling you what he thought the 10
greatest Pilots were he probably differs
from me but like that's going to be a
solid list of Pilots right bad Pilots it
kind of is about what was bad about it
right so I think that's an interesting
study like if you asked your 10 of your
friends what was the worst TV pilot you
ever watched and then go watch them
you could still learn like I think one
of the biggest mistakes that pilots make
is especially nowadays
the studios and the networks are like
more twists more twists more twists and
you're just exhausted by the end of the
pilot you're like i k like I was done
three three twists ago
I that was enough I didn't need the
other things like give me those later so
it's too much happening in the pilot
right and that's a battle right now
because that's what they're asking us to
do but it's too much sometimes just too
much you need to say it's too much it's
overwhelming story nobody's going to
want to come back
um
sometimes it's about the focus being off
like
that whoever your lead character is
maybe it's casting maybe it's writing
who knows is is losing focus to another
character and so it feels a little all
over the place and it's like well why
didn't they fix that why didn't they
realize it right there's a lot of things
that can go wrong in a pilot sometimes
it's just the directing is bad and
you're like wow this was a really good
script it's like too bad they didn't
have a better director because it just
it feels flat and like not good and you
know they spend a ton of money on it but
it doesn't feel like it you don't see it
on screen
so it's it's an interesting exercise to
sort of just make yourself think about
like what would I have done different if
it was my show
what questions does a writer need to be
asking themselves while they're writing
a pilot
I'd say first and foremost always be
clear on why you're writing it what
about it is interesting to you what
message are you trying to convey
why why is it need to exist because I
guarantee you if it's not a thing you've
already sold
when you go out to have conversations
about it people are going to be like so
why why did you write this pilot you're
going to get it so know why you're doing
it because it'll also keep you really
focused in the writing process
um I I was working on a pilot once and I
had written the outline
and I had outlined two pilots at the
same time and chose to write another one
first so I came back to this one and was
like great now I'm going to write this
and as I was writing it
I just had this overwhelming sense of
like no something's wrong something's
wrong and what I realized is having done
so many cop shows
usually the secondary characters you
want to write for them in the writer's
room and the studio and the network are
like nobody cares nobody cares too many
people like we're focused on this
and so I had all these secondary
characters in my world and I took them
all out because I was like maybe later
these characters could exist but in this
pilot nobody cares and so I had to then
go back and weave in
really important story points that those
characters had once carried
because that information was still
important to my story but the characters
weren't
so it was like right you're pulling
Focus away from this really important
story that you're trying to tell about a
woman whose personal and professional
life has been upended by having these
other people in the mix
so because I knew she was the most
important thing to me in the story I was
able to be like something's wrong
something's wrong what is it and then I
finally figured it out
so you were having too much of these
ancillary characters steel sort of
screen time yes oh interesting yeah
still screen time and and more so than
screen time it's trying to steal
importance right because in a pilot
you want every character to pop a little
bit or it's why are they in there right
so suddenly you're trying to create
moments for all these sort of
second-tier characters but I want all
the moments to be with like the four
people I'm most invested in who are all
tied to my main character so I was like
we don't really need all these I will
wipe the decks clearer
and then get all those moments of you
know and that script has gotten me so
many meetings and and you know so much
development opportunity because I did
that because I narrowed the focus
so while you're writing it's really
important I think who your audience is
if you're writing a pilot that feels
very broadcast to you let it be
broadcast don't try to make it you know
well maybe it's also a cable pilot
though no sometimes it's fine for a
pilot to just feel like a broadcast
pilot and sometimes you're going to
write something that's like grittier and
a little more Cutting Edge and it's very
clearly a streaming pilot and that's
fine write it that way
it's a little it's hard when you write
things that are right down the middle
because then everyone's a little
confused by where it goes
like what what's your target for this
who are you thinking of so if you think
ahead of time like I have a pilot that I
wrote that is very specifically I wrote
it as an fx pilot because I wanted to
show that I could do that like premium
cable sort of feel right even though FX
is regular cable it's pretty premium
Fair on that channel so I was like I'm
gonna do that if one Pilot's very
specifically an HBO pilot because I was
like okay I can do this it's not
necessarily how I want most of my shows
to be but I can do this and this show
fits the mold so I'm going to write it
and then I have shows that are straight
broadcast or more like Disney Plessy
kind of genre sort of stuff it's just
sort of no in your head like because
again it's a question you're going to
get asked right if you write that pilot
and an exec's interested in it or a
producer is interested in it they're
gonna say so where'd you see this
so no know where you see it as you're
writing it
when if we use that example of the a
woman who's professional and personal
life or sort of upended when they asked
you why did you write this what was your
what was my answer it was I it was at a
time when several stories in the media
and on television quite frankly had
coalesced for me in this idea of women
who had done hard things in their lives
being expected to be ashamed of it women
who maybe had done sex work or done
whatever needing to feel shame and I
rejected that I was like no like these
women survived they did what they had to
do to stay alive and they are survivors
and they have built wonderful lives for
themselves and why should they have to
feel guilty about this thing that they
did
and so everything about her story is a
rebuttal of that idea it is about a
woman who made some really really
difficult choices when she was young
and owns them and it's not like she's
proud of them and wants to flaunt them
all the time but she refuses to feel
shame about them
how much of the world needs to be
created in the pilot you know that's an
interesting question I would say again
it sort of depends on the show right if
you are writing a genre or a fantasy
show I think
you need to have a sense of what rules
need to absolutely be clear in the pilot
especially if it involves magic or it
involves superpowers or anything like
that
Executives tend to get a little
mystified by that stuff so clear rules
are very helpful to them even if you
know that you're going to build off on
that and expand on that as you continue
the writing process if it becomes a show
what's absolutely essential in the pilot
that your audience knows and so that's
part of your world building right is
like okay in this if you're writing a
fantasy show let's say that in this
Kingdom there's this kind of magic and
in this Kingdom there's this kind of
magic and here's what happens when that
kind of magic you know bumps up against
each other that might be all we need to
know in the pilot but make sure that the
rules of all that are very clear
if you're writing more of a sort of
let's say like a Gray's Anatomy kind of
show it's you really want the characters
to pop you want to be sure that each
character is incredibly distinct
and that we understand what's most
important to you about those characters
from the pilot now you're also creating
a scenario that's going to tell us how
the show works so for instance using
Grays as an example interns in a in a
Residency program all the stuff getting
thrown at them and then also
commiserating with each other and
building a relationship with each other
to get through it
easy to understand that's what the show
is but that's all set up in the pilot so
a lot of times what you'll hear is you
know
what's the engine and it really is about
what is helping the audience understand
what to expect every week
so if it's a cop show we understand that
we get a case every week or if it's like
say Bosch on Amazon we maybe have
multiple cases that we're going to
follow through the season and every week
we're going to get more pieces of the
puzzle and we're also going to get all
this personal stuff going on but you
establish that in your pilot like this
is kind of how the show works
so to me that's the most important stuff
and you can always add more to the world
later a lot of times what will happen is
exactly as you know I was telling you in
that other pilot I had to clear some
characters out
sometimes you're like I really want to
introduce this character in The Pilot
because you know they're going to be in
the entire show
but there's just it just is taking up
room in that pilot in a way that's just
a disservice to the story and you have
to be brave enough to pull it out and
hold it
for later in the series because what's
most important is that what the show is
is incredibly clear by the time someone
finishes reading that pilot
they understand the show that you're
trying to make they definitely should
have questions about like well like is
this thing going to pay off and is this
character going to come back and you
know they'll have all kinds of questions
because you want open-ended things you
want there to be Mysteries and and
wondering about how the characters are
going to interact with each other but
how the show will work every single
episode is what you're really trying to
get across on top of your cool
characters and your awesome world and
all that stuff you're painting that
picture for them
how does a writer end a pilot so one of
the first things that I got taught when
I started writing Pilots is certainly in
a in a I'm trying to break into the
business I'm writing writing samples
part of the pilot writing process
you you do not hold anything back story
wise in the pilot so if you're like
all this stuff's gonna happen in the
pilot and then we're gonna open episode
two with like a the Chase and a crash
and this character's gonna die I'm gonna
tell you that's the end of your pilot
right because you want to go big
emotionally or action-wise or something
you want it to be like bam at the end of
your pilot so
I wrote one I wrote a pilot where it's
about this political family and
um it's it a hundred percent when you
read it you're like oh this guy's gonna
die he's gonna die he's totally gonna
die and then he doesn't die someone else
dies at the end of Act five and
everybody's so mad at me it's so mad at
me when they read it but then act six is
telling you exactly where we're going
it's like how this what where the family
members are left now now that this the
anchor has fallen away and what's going
to happen and it goes out on this sense
of like oh my God how are they gonna
survive this
because you're like how are they going
to survive it that's what you want
someone to say to you right at the end
of that pilot if you're doing a mystery
pilot you know you can
um you can do that thing where we think
we're at the end of the episode it feels
like we've had like this really exciting
fulfilling hour and then like the screen
goes black and then you write you know
but then a door opens and a figure walks
through and we know everything's about
to change out it's like that kind of
stuff that like really makes them want
to know what happens in the next episode
so it can be very it can be description
it can be a line of dialogue it's
whatever it is to you that says gotta
come back next week
and and that's really really true when
you're starting to write them people
want to hold things back because they're
like but then later but then later but
right now there's no later there's only
this if you sell this pilot you can say
hey I'd really love to pull this out and
hold it for later but right now you just
want them to be blown away by your
writing so
I've heard writers say this it has not
really been my experience but it does
happen to a lot of writers that
oftentimes how you think your pilot ends
is really how your pilot begins not a
Stanton not a rule but sometimes if
people are telling you it just moves too
slow or it just doesn't feel like it has
enough momentum that's a thing to try is
pull the ending up and then right from
that and see what happens
and that's not like bookending it where
you okay that's different not book any
that's literally like that cool amazing
moment that you think is the end of the
pilot might actually be where we need to
start
and then what's in your head is episode
two is really the pilot right so you're
you're using the end of the pilot that
you thought you needed and then kind of
writing episode two
which sometimes really works sometimes
it's like oh right because you were
saving all that cool stuff
and you didn't realize it and now all
the cool stuff from episode two is in
your pilot
are there any other tips you have for
writing a pilot
um maybe we didn't cover you know I
would say this if especially if you're
new to television
um learning to outline is a really
important skill and so if you have not
habitually been a writer who outlines
their material start with the pilots
that you're writing at home
and
um sometimes you can find those examples
again like at the writer's Guild library
or places like that
um I in my book The Writer's room
Survival Guide have a couple of examples
of what an outline can look like to just
help people start to figure out you know
what is that what is this outline thing
I have to do because the more you
practice it at home the less
intimidating it's going to be when a
sure Runners like great can you write me
a 12-page Outline by the end of the week
like you're gonna be like sure I can
because you've done it at home right so
it'll be it won't be like a new thing
that's getting dropped on you
and it also just is a good
guide map once you have that outline
writing your pilot it's going to be so
much easier because
as you're loading in like you know
you're like okay and then like now this
is the next scene in the outline
sometimes you can already be like oh
wait I feel like it took us too long to
get here let me go back really quickly
and change this or oh no actually I
think this goes later I'm gonna hold
this scene and do it later as opposed to
you being on the Fly trying to make it
all up as you're going along
so it's a really good skill to have it's
very necessary in television writing so
I would start practicing it now at home
and and whatever your thing is that you
love while you write I happen to write
to television because I'm a classic
latchkey kid who did her homework with
the TV on
um but music quiet whatever it is
embrace it love it just know that when
you become a TV writer if you have a
boss who says please work in the office
you're going to have to find a way to
make that work for you for me I was
lucky because I came along when
streaming existed so I could still put
TV on and just put my headphones in and
have Friday Night Lights playing in the
background while I wrote so
um but you know whatever how however
you're writing Jam you know works for
you you will have to create a version of
that that works in an office where
people can walk in your door and
interrupt you and do all those things so
just remember that that it's it's very
different once you become a working TV
writer
is there a standard structure for
television
yeah and and it can vary especially
depending on what your what Outlet
you're writing for so when you're
staffed right you're writing to whatever
the network or the streaming service
does
there's there's a variety of different
structures that that brings about for
instance most of the ABC dramas that I
know of I will not say all about any of
them are written in 6X structure so what
6X structure means is that you're you're
basically everything's kind of a little
symmetrical right you've got this many
pages here this many pages in each Act
get building to those act out through
those commercial breaks and because it's
so act out driven it really changes the
pacing of the show if you watch most ABC
shows will feel like they move very
quickly and it's because of that sort of
symmetrical nature of the ax
shows on CBS are often teaser 4 is the
structure it's also often called five
act structure it sort of just depends on
who's referring to it but what it does
is allow you to write a longer teaser
that can sometimes be more luxurious and
get more of your story set up
and then you you use the following four
acts to you know complete your
storytelling shows that I I will say I
think have done that or like The Good
Wife right would sometimes have those
really long opening setups before the
title card so that's your long luxurious
teaser and then the rest of the show is
the 5x structure
um
so those that's sort of the main stuff
six act teaser four or five Act five act
tends to
um
have a shorter teaser that then the
basically starts act one so it's like
short teaser title card rest of act one
as opposed to being a separate entity
like teaser four is
um so those are the varying sort of
different things and you can you know
again if you can get a hold of scripts
for different shows you can research how
they did it in streaming shows when you
read our scripts there there won't be
any act designations because there are
typically no commercial breaks although
now that you know Netflix is going to
have an ad tier I don't know if that's
going to change or they're going to ask
us to tell them where the commercial
breaks are like we do in broadcast TBD
but
um again to something I spoke about
earlier and that I think is really
important breaking the story as if those
act breaks exist
will help with your storytelling and
help with the emotional ebb and flow of
the episode so that it doesn't feel like
you're waiting till the end of the show
to do all the really important things
because I think what happens is people
are like well we can have all these nice
long conversations or we can have this
great big huge set piece but then you're
not really getting a lot of variation in
the episode it's just sort of like talk
talk talk talk everything happens where
it's like talking talking huge set piece
talking and talking talking talking boom
ending and that's like a it's not really
a great pleasurable experience when you
watch TV you want to sort of like be
drawn in and then like okay I can rest a
little bit
um so that that act break structure even
if you take act breaks out of your
script is a really good way to do it
how is the structure of a Netflix
60-minute show different from a
60-minute cable TV show
the biggest difference is are you if
you're referring to Cable as in like
free form effects those kind of things
are that those platforms still include
commercial breaks so you are still
writing to an act out and what that
really means for the writer is that you
are creating a moment that you hope
assures that your audience will come
back after the commercial break now
obviously some those shows will move to
a streaming platform there will not be
commercials in them so you that gets
eliminated at that point but when
they're airing on their actual
originating broadcasters that's the
whole goal that's what an act out is all
about is holy crap what just happened
and you're like come on commercials come
on commercials go go Google or you
recorded it so you can fast forward
through all the commercials and then
your show is back
um so you know for a streaming show for
say Netflix or
for you know Amazon or for free well
freebie has ads but for Amazon Prime
itself those are not they're not worried
about your act breaks so you can you
lose page count in your script to act
breaks when you're doing them for say a
broadcast show like when you have four
lines at the top of a page and then it's
like end of act you're done with that
page like all that blank space is lost
to you if you're doing a streaming show
and you're breaking it with AC breaks
but you're not putting them in the
script it's just one long continuous
thing so you've probably bought yourself
back four pages of script just by not
having act breaks so it'll allow you to
expand a little bit sometimes when you
need to
um the trick with the
60 Minute show I have eaten yet to write
on a Netflix show and I have written on
three of them now where 60 Minute
episodes were actually what we were
delivering we both still delivered like
52 wish 50 52 to 55 minutes
so in general I know they have shows
that will have longer episodes but in
general that's still the target so
you're still looking at you know turning
in a 52 to 55 page script in the hopes
of not you don't ever want to run short
but you also don't want to be 10 minutes
over because now you're going to have to
kill a lot of scenes that you love in
order to get it down
so trying to find that sweet spot of
being like four or five minutes over so
you can cut a few things but you know
still have some choices and some some
good moments around is kind of the goal
can you explain a b and c stories sure
so
in most shows you will have your a story
is the main story of the episode it is
the driving story usually of your main
characters
uh not always true but often true
and so say for instance and I'll use
SWAT as an example because we very
clearly wrote A B and C stories so your
a story is the crime of the week right
what who are the bad guys who are
challenging what have they done what are
we trying to stop them from doing
and you will develop that whole story
and who in our cast is that story really
affecting right now 8 out of 10 episodes
that's going to be Hondo but sometimes
it's a personal case from the past for
one of our other characters or it's
someone's friend was injured in the
crime and so they're the ones who are
emotionally affected by what we're doing
so that's your a story your B story and
your C story
are the supporting stories in the
episode and they are usually more
character focused
so it's a chance for your second tier
characters to sort of get moments right
so say again in an episode of SWAT a b
story might be
um
Street and Chris have like admitted that
they like each other but they're still
like oh can we date no we can't date
what are we gonna do about this mess so
that romantic Intrigue is your B story
sometimes it also will cross into your a
story right because it's like
they're on a call together and they've
just had this fight about the fact that
they can't date each other but then like
something dangerous happens and that
it's so clear that how much they love
each other right so it's like you're
building that stuff into the a story but
you're breaking their arc on its own
and then a c story is usually a runner
right it's like a three four beat story
that sometimes adds some humor to the
episode sometimes it's to tie off a
loose end that we've left floating from
a prior episode of like did that couple
break up we don't know and so we'll do
like three beats where we finally reveal
like did the couple break up oh no no
they're still together look at that
surprise like whatever it is
um sometimes it's a way to give an actor
who has maybe not been as focused on in
the show a chance to shine so you're
giving them three or four scenes that
are really about them and their
character and letting them sort of like
you know hey I'm here pay attention to
me so
that's really what those things break
down to it's your main story your
secondary story and then see story is
usually a runner
um you will sometimes like in a finale
episode your B and C stories will feel
about equal because you know finales are
all about wrapping up the emotional arcs
of the entire season so sometimes it's
like you've got three relationship
stories going and you have to get
somewhere with all of them so
you'll you know you suss that out in the
moment but that's in general how that
works
what do writers get wrong about TV
structure I think the imbalance can
happen a lot the everything happens in
the beginning or the end and not enough
attention to holding the story in the
middle right you you can start with a
big bang but you have to keep building
investment through the episode or else
people won't be around to see your big
finish
so it's just that reminder of like the
story has to keep building on itself and
sometimes you see people like just sort
of think this story can coast and it it
can't like you need to keep building the
investment of your audience of like oh
my God she overheard that is she gonna
tell them she ever heard it you're
waiting to find out like is she gonna
tell them and then maybe you don't even
get an answer that episode but like I'm
leaning forward now because I'm like she
ever heard the thing though she ever
heard the thing so it's just that it's I
think that's the biggest mistake is not
realizing that you can have a big
beginning and a big finish but if the
stuff in between isn't peaking the
interest of your audience they're gonna
tune out and that's the worst thing that
can happen to you because they may not
make it to your big finish
and so you can't count on that to be why
someone's going to keep watching the
show
what does it mean to break a story
so breaking a story is how you figure
out what all the actual scenes are in an
episode whether it's your own pilot
you're writing at home or whether it's
an episode of a show that you're working
on and there are different methodologies
about how to do it
I can tell you my favorite methodology
of doing it which is I and this is a
combination of ways I've seen it done in
multiple rooms that like now this is the
system that I like so first of all I
think it's just a question of what did
we think our main characters would be
doing in this episode right and if
you're doing a pilot it's like what is
the story I want to tell about my main
characters and you can on note cards or
on a whiteboard as simply as you know I
need Nicole to figure this out I need
um you know Adam to go here I need
um you know we need conflicts between
the mother and daughter to get us to the
place we need to be in the next episode
Big Ideas like that they don't have to
be super specific it's just like you
know here are things we think our
characters need to do
and especially if you're working on
staff right and you're in a writer's
room
the next part of that is do we owe
anything from the last episode was there
stuff that we thought we were going to
include in that script that we didn't do
we still need it does it go here so you
have that conversation and then you look
at the episode coming up and like have
we set up everything we need to for that
or do we owe something in this episode
to make sure that we get to episode six
you know clean and nobody's like what
where'd that come from so to me those
were all the starting conversations
and once you do that you kind of have a
loose shape of the episode right you you
have say five things you know that your
leading man has to just to deal with
like five scenes with your leading man
three scenes that are about his
relationship with his Leading Lady maybe
two scenes of the leading ladies story
on her own and then oh we have to set up
this plot Point that's going to pay off
in episode six oh we want to do a b
story about this set of secondary
characters and you're just talking it
through what is it once you have that
you can start to really talk about
what's happening in those actual scenes
so it's like okay in the scene where
Nicole's going to get the document and
she's going to be super pissed off about
it like what is she doing where do we
find her you know is she in her morning
routine is she on the phone like you're
really talking that through because if
she's on the phone maybe she's saying
something that's going to set up one of
those B stories we need later right you
can see if you can make connective
tissue between that scene and the scene
that needs to happen later and then what
does that paperwork mean why is she so
angry about it is she screaming at
someone is she throwing a fit in a room
by herself like what is it so you really
sort of nail down what's happening in
that scene and you do that for every one
of those moments that you've already
talked about
and then once you have them all fleshed
out and how many scenes are in an
episode will vary between what show
you're on I would say
it has been my experience that if you
have more than 35 scenes your script's
probably going to be too long because
you want to be able to write you know
the description that the art department
needs to figure out what they're
decorating and you need to you know if
there's a specific costume thing you
need costumes to do you got to describe
it and that kind of stuff so you need
some room to play with those
descriptions or with a long exchange of
dialogue
and so say now you have your 35 scenes
well now you got to figure out what
order they go in
so that's the next stage of the break is
to say okay well I think that one we
have here is the perfect ACT out for act
two so you move it to the bottom of act
two and then it's like okay well we know
this is the end of the episode so we're
going to move this here and we know this
is the first scene that we want to do
and you just literally start moving the
cards or writing on the board to put the
things in order
and then you end up with an episode of
television and then that doesn't
necessarily mean your work is done right
especially if you're staffed
you're going to pitch stuff along the
way like the day you do that big
overview conversation your show Runner
comes in if they were off doing other
things and you put the room will pitch
in the stuff on the board or her and
they'll be like oh I love all that I'm
not so sure about this maybe come up
with some alts for that so you keep you
know doing the work in each process
until you get to that we have 35 scenes
in order that feels like an episode and
then the writer of the episode or the
number two in the room will pitch
through the whole episode for the
showrunner and the share Runner will
sometimes just love it and like great go
write an outline and sometimes the
showrunner is making adjustments as
you're pitching and being like no no I
love that can you do me a favor though
and make sure
um we don't do X because actor a has a
problem with that so just find an ALT
for that end of the the scene great make
yourself a note keep pitching
and you'll take all that information
with you and then go write the outline
so it's really the building blocks
breaking a story is coming up with the
building blocks of the episode
when you're breaking a TV show story
what are the first few things you're
trying to figure out
if it's
if it's for a thing that you're writing
yourself right I mean you have the idea
of what you think the show is so
where it starts I think is always like
an important thing to nail down where
what moment is the first moment of this
show for you
um what is the way you want to introduce
your main character or characters what's
the the way that you want the audience
to interpret them based on their
movement where they live where how they
dress whatever the key elements are to
you
so I think figuring those things out
right away is really important and
I I would say in Pilot writing if you I
always know how my pilot ends in terms
of the broad sense of I know the ending
is going to be that we're going to
realize that character a is actually the
one who committed the murder and nobody
else knows it right that's going to be
the reveal at the end of the pilot so
everything I'm writing is writing
towards that and that'll help you sort
of know like oh I don't have enough
twists or turns or that kind of thing so
I feel like knowing how you start
knowing how you want to introduce your
characters
and knowing where the pilot is ending to
me are the most important things when
you're trying to then go break the story
um when you're breaking it in a room
with other writers I think you know
having tent pools of the episode are
what what we refer to it as of like you
know you cannot necessarily know how the
episode's supposed to end other than I
know we're supposed to get to the point
where he admits he loves her at the end
of the episode I'm not quite sure how to
get there but I know that's how we're
ending and I I know at the midpoint we
need to have something go wrong where
everybody's at each other's throats and
they're going to have to recover from
that for the rest of the episode and
then my idea for how to start the
episode is X and then your team can help
you fill in all the other stuff in
between that's the joy of having a
writer's room is you don't need to have
all the answers like you do when you're
writing your pilot you can say here's
what I have and then everybody else
joins together to help you fill in the
parts that you don't have and you don't
have to take every idea that comes
unless it's from your showrunner and
then you kind of do but
if someone pitches something that you
don't love it's okay to be like can we
try and beat that like I'm not sure I
like I really want to go down that road
and if your showrunner likes it and may
make you do it but it's fine to be like
can we come up with some alts for that
and then you pitch the version you like
best to your showrunner and sometimes
they're like oh I love that and that
conversation's over and sometimes
they're like I'm not sure about that act
out track three though and then you can
be like well we have some other ideas in
the room and you can pitch the thing you
didn't love but that someone in the room
pitched and maybe the showrunner is
going to be like yes do that okay
because it's not your show so you do it
when it's your pilot you get to make all
the choices until you're doing it for a
studio or a network and then they can
say to you I don't like the act out for
actually
or I don't do notes yes but that sounds
like that's the beauty of the of the
cards is or doing it with a board is
it's movable parts and so you can show
them if you say okay we can try it even
though maybe in your mind you're like
this is never going to work but we'll
we'll go with it we'll try it so you
move it here and then you show okay if I
move that then I have to move this here
and then it's kind of there for you to
see yes and that's the best part of it
is like you try it and then everyone can
see like oh wait that means that like
now all the actions shifted to the
middle of the episode and we don't have
anything up here so how do we fix that
and it's maybe it's moving back the
thing that you just moved and we find a
different solution for here so it allows
you to see it and then have the
conversation and I think you know the
story that I love about why I'm still a
note card girl like I have
um boards like in my house that I just
pull out and like stick note cards to
them and I have one up on the wall
and um part of the reason that I am a
note card girl is because of the
legendary story of um Stephen bochko and
the Hill Street Blues pilot which when
they first screened it was kind of a
disaster
and he was like give me a chance to fix
it and he went back to his office and he
laid the entire episode and note cards
out on the floor
and he reassembled the pilot moving the
cards around and pulling cards out and
then that became the pilot that changed
television so being able to put all the
cards out and be like
okay there's just too much in act two
that's the problem because now that all
the cards are lined up I can just tell
Act 2 is too long so what do I do or you
know
just saying like nope I need this to
happen sooner and moving the physical
card now on a board you can do that
because you're Crossing stuff out or you
know whatever but
it's to me it's easier with cards
there's also now the electronic software
that we've all had to use during Zoom
rooms like writer's room Pro or Miro and
you know for people who prefer to do it
that way and I think final draft even
has a board function now and so even for
yourself you can use those programs if
you want to because you don't want to
actually write on physical note cards or
you don't have room to have a whiteboard
you can use those programs to do the
same thing
just as a side note do you know did they
have to shoot new scenes for Hill Street
Blues or did they just do it in post I
believe it was just a recut I feel like
I I read bachka's book and I feel like
it was just a recut I could be wrong
because I haven't read the book since
2016.
um
but yeah it was just a like it's too
long it's kind of all over the place and
so they went in and they they
reassembled it they reimagined it with
those cards
how much time is a writer's room given
to break a story
um very determined by the showrunner and
their process but I would say in general
it's about a week per episode
um sometimes longer especially if it's a
really serialized show and it's
streaming show where you're writing
everything before it shoots the 20 weeks
of the writer's room can sort of if you
have 20 weeks can sort of stretch each
episode break a little further because
you have more time in broadcast
television once the train of the season
starts running you have to keep running
to or else it will run you over so a
week is about as long as I think I've
ever had and a week like meaning seven
days
um
shorter if if you can is always
preferred
um but yeah it's no one wants to rush an
episode off the board because if you do
you always end up putting it back on the
board when you go right the outline and
stuff doesn't work and then you know
it's like okay and you put the cards
back up and you're like let's fix it so
it's better to take the time to fix it
while it's there
um another thing that can happen in a
break is that
people different different people prefer
different things as writers when you're
breaking your episode that you're gonna
write
um I think it's always great to have a
conversation in the room about like how
do we get into the scene how do we get
out
um
because that's helpful right it sort of
short hands for you about like you know
I just need to come into the scene while
they're already sitting at the table
arguing I don't need the build up and
whatever but there's a lot of things
that I'm like you guys I can figure that
out I don't need to talk about it like I
I will figure out how we get out of the
scene like I just don't need to have a
conversation about it some writers
really need to have that conversation
and so you need to say like hey it would
be really helpful for me if we talked
about how we're getting in and out of
everything
I tend to be like I just need to know
what's happening in the scene I don't
need the the how we get in how we get
out I'm going to figure that out on the
page let's just make sure we have every
moment that we need in the scene written
on this card so that I know what it what
all has to happen
so it's a little bit different depending
on your writing style I think
and does each writer get its own episode
their own episode or each episode is a
collective
process
very show dependent
um my experience has been that every
writer either gets a solo episode or
co-writes episodes
um
throughout the season so most standard
is each solo Rider gets at least one
episode that they write themselves
writing teams will write an episode
together and then sometimes like in
order for a staff writer to get more
experience they'll pair the staff writer
with a coep to write so they get to
write another half a script so that they
get more of a chance to write or in a
room that has the episodes to do it you
really want your writer writer's
assistant to get a chance to write so
you'll pair your writer's assistant with
a more experienced writer so they get a
chance so oftentimes that'll turn into
like one one and a half scripts per
writer per team depending on how it
works out
um
there are circumstances in which staff
writers do not get to write a script
because the room is super top heavy and
there's only a limited number say
there's
eight writers in the room
and there's eight episodes of Television
well at least the first one's already
written probably because your
showrunner's already written the pilot
your showrunner's probably writing the
finale so now there's six episodes left
and there's eight writers so unless they
pair you up with someone you may not get
a script
um but it's still a great experience and
you'll still get to learn lots of things
and what most showrunners will try to do
in that case is like give the staff
writer a chance to write the story
documents or to help with the outlines
or do things that like give them
experience even though they're not
writing a script I should give you a
little more on that probably too
um
there is there are shows that do all
group writing
it is my least preferred method of
writing a show
um but there are show Runners who swear
by it and if it works for them it's
their right to do it but that is where
literally like you do that whole
breaking process you have all your
scenes and it gets divvied up amongst
the entire staff and so people write
scenes and then it all gets assembled
and you know the showrunner does passes
on it whatever once there's a completed
episode someone on the staff will be
credited with having written it
um if it remains a completely group
Endeavor there are some shows where we
group write the first draft and then I
as the writer of that episode will take
it and do a pass to try to make it all
cohesive and then I will be in control
of the script with the showrunner for
the rest of the run and then it is you
know to allow the writer to take more
ownership over it
um I I believe group writing is good in
emergencies like when your lead actor
suddenly has to disappear for three days
um but I am not about it as a general
rule but plenty of people do it is there
a danger though in that there are going
to be different voices and styles that
are going to be very noticeable if it's
100 100 which is why someone even if
it's the share Runner is going to have
to take that Frankenstein draft is what
we call them and go make a cohesive
feeling episode like it's never going to
be right when you first assemble all the
pieces like it's just not everybody has
a different take on slightly different
way that they like to write this
character versus that character this
writer does and so you as a showrunner
will have to go in and or assign a
writer to do it but you someone has to
make it cohesive so that it feels like
one writer wrote it
sure and then if it's different episodes
that there's also the danger in that
each one's going to sound or have a
different style and tempo
yeah I mean that is a danger the real
truth of the matter is the showrunner is
should I I believe I will say should be
taking the final pants on every script
because at the end of the day it is the
showrunner's job to make sure every
episode feels like it belongs together
so you know you may have a really
talented writer who doesn't quite get
the voice of the show right part of your
job as the showrunner is to take that
script and adjust it so that the voice
feels right and send it on through and
not put your name on it because this is
your job and allow that writer to take
full credit for the episode because
they've done their work your job as the
showrunner is to take it to the final
level
does everyone in the room obsess over
the season finale on the first day
no no I think it's pretty rare because
sometimes I mean I have literally been
in situations where on the first day we
don't even know what the season's about
so all you're hoping for in that case is
that someone figures it out because you
know to me really good show Runners are
prepared and they come in and they're
like okay here's the the big idea of the
season is X and then we can all start
riffing on that but sometimes you're in
a room where someone literally says to
you what is the season about and you're
like I thought that was your job and so
now you all start riffing trying to come
up with something that the showrunner
latches on to and then it's like okay
that let's talk more about that and then
you can start building it so really the
you know once you start talking about
what those tent poles are and your show
Runners start saying like oh and then
maybe this would be cool at the end of
the season this would be cool like
you're you're building a list of what
might be in the finale but until you
really start getting ready to pitch the
season to the studio and the network
you're more concerned on just making
sure you actually have
6 8 13
uh you know 22 Episodes like that you
know that you're gonna have those
episodes because
you can you know Netflix oftentimes will
ask you to pitch a whole season in three
two to three weeks so you're just in
there basically and and by pitch a
season I mean have big ideas for what
the season is so you're just in there
like okay what if we did an episode
about this and he's like yes write it on
the board like you're just trying to
come up with ideas and half of it will
go away
by the time you actually get to the end
of the season because you're you come up
with better ideas once you have more
time
so yeah I I don't think I've ever
experienced a show where someone was
like
this is how the season ends on the first
day and we were all like so just like
into that it was more like okay how are
we gonna get there
how do you know you have enough story
for the entire season
um
I would say the one of the bigger
problems honestly is that you usually
have more story than you have room for
like especially in streaming where
you're only getting eight six to eight
ten episodes
um you will find that there's stuff that
you really want to do that you just
can't get to
because you know to some of the points
that we've talked about that main
character or main character relationship
is going to always need attention and if
you really need a b story to pay off in
the finale that b story has to keep
getting serviced and so you're going to
have great ideas for things that you
want to do and they're going to stay on
a board for maybe next season because
it's just you end up having more ideas
than you have space for now if you're
doing a season of say SWAT where you've
got 22 Episodes
it's it's part of the reason that you
have a room the size that you have for
that right where you have 10 to 12
bodies to just constantly be coming in
being like what if we did an episode
about this what if we did an episode
about that because then you're worried
you won't have enough
um crimes right you can make the
character stories work but it's like you
need 22 crimes what are the 22 crimes
going to be so it's that brainstorming
session of like you know maybe this
maybe this and maybe this and then you
put some down and some of them go away
and some of them become stories you know
and you're always looking when you work
on that type of show you're always
reading newspapers and looking at TV
shows and doing stuff trying to be like
oh what if we did this case and you just
kind of keep a running list because you
never know when like exactly the case
that we were all so excited about we're
like this one's going to be great and
then you try to break it and you're like
oh this isn't an episode
what are we going to do and then you go
to your list
you like this one let's do this one
how many storylines are in a typical
season of a show
that's I don't know that I can answer
that because again I think it varies so
much depending on the type of show that
you're doing
um
you know so I wrote on a show called
fate the wing Saga and so we had you
know five girls who were the focus of
our show so each of them has to have
some some sort of story that we're
following right so you know each one of
them has a storyline and then there's a
romantic storyline between our lead and
the handsome boy at the school and then
there's a storyline about the secret
that the teachers are keeping
and it starts to be a lot and it's sort
of the trick is the management of how
those you want those things to all
eventually sort of cross over each other
and touch each other and weave together
the problem is when you suddenly find
yourself with like 10 stories that are
all sort of separate
and and you're like I don't I don't know
like we can't this character is not
participating with any of the other
characters how do we get her involved in
these stories and then you have to like
change the path of that character's art
because you you don't want them on an
island all by themselves you want them
in the main story somehow and part of
that Core group of characters so a lot
of it is I really want to do this for
this character and you'll love the story
but you realize it's pulling them out of
the main Arc and so you have to find a
way to pull them back or you have to
choose different stories for them
how do you structure the story lines
into an episode that's what we call
um blending or weaving or as one of my
show owners love to call it the smush
and that is when you know you have all
your storyline beats out and now you
have to put them in an order that
actually works as an episode of
television and so that's that's a lot of
that you know
um I think this is definitely how I want
to end act three I think this is a great
way to kick off Act five I think
um you know we really want this
relationship turmoil to start in act two
and then boil over in act four so like
you're just sort of trying to figure out
the rhythm of the episode and it's a lot
of moving cards around or changing
things on a whiteboard or moving your
electronic cards but you finally kind of
get a feel for
okay this this works this is an episode
because you're looking out for all kinds
of things right you want your main
characters can't disappear for too long
so if you find that like they're at the
top of act two and then we don't see our
main characters again to like the middle
of act three that's a problem so now you
gotta go rearrange some stuff
um you want to make sure that you're
tracking the stories enough so that no
one's like they're just not going to
talk about that thing anymore so like
even for your c-story Runner that's only
three beats it's like okay if we launch
it in act two and then we need to touch
it in like four and six to pay it off so
that you're not just forgetting about it
so it's it's that kind of balancing act
it's like you're trying to make sure
that you're giving the audience a good
flow of information through the episode
in the beginning of your writing career
how are you green on the business side
of being a TV writer
oh my God I was so green about the whole
thing it's you know when your first
break in right the writer's Guild one of
the main things that they do for us is
the negotiate the
um MBA which is our minimum basic
agreement with the studios so there's
set amounts that studio that staff
writers will make so it's written down
it's like they're in a piece of paper so
you don't have to there's not a ton of
negotiation when you're a staff writer
but as you go on like all of this stuff
gets very complicated and there's you
know issues of um how long a studio can
hold you and how much more they have to
pay you to hold you and it gets very
complicated which is why having a rep
that you can communicate with is so
important because I have literally just
had to say to my agent my manager
sometimes like what does this mean like
I don't understand this what does this
mean
and you know just in terms of
how
how your career is going to build it's
sort of like an idea in the beginning
but it really is sort of
one job at a time one project at a time
because I very much my reps would tell
you every time a project ends I'm like
you're gonna be able to find me another
job right and they're like girl of
course you're gonna find another job but
I can't believe my own press so I'm
always like am I gonna want another job
though
um but it's you know paying attention to
the business paying attention to all
this consolidation that's going on
um you know are the people that you knew
who worked at Netflix getting laid off
or did they survive the layoffs because
sometimes you're reaching out to the
people you know to say like hey I have
this project and I'm looking for someone
who might be interested in it does it
seem to you like one of your overall
people might be interested in this or
something you know to your friends and
if your friends are in these Mass
layoffs now they're off looking for
different work
um
how systems change you know having
worked at marble TV in its old
Incarnation and then that whole thing
going away so everybody I knew who
worked for Marvel didn't work for Marvel
anymore you know in a matter of a year
so the whole Marvel TV landscape has
changed and so it's like okay who who
does work over there do I know anyone
there so you're you're constantly having
to pay attention to the evolution of
this business there are people who
choose not to there are people who are
like that's just too much for me I don't
want to deal with it I like to be
informed about all those things I think
it's really important to me so that when
my agent sends me something from a
particular Studio or a producing pod
that I am like oh they're connected to
this place I don't really love maybe I
don't want to look at this or oh I love
that place so yes let's definitely work
there
um so it I just think that edge you're
always educating yourself not just about
your skill set that you need as a writer
but about
how to be you know how to be a share
runner in the future about how this
business works
about what good representation looks
like you know I constantly have younger
writers saying to me you know like
um having this problem with my agent but
I don't want to say anything and I'm
like no no your agent works for you
they work for you you want to have a
good partnership with them but they get
paid because you get paid so it's fine
to go to them and say hey I'm a little
concerned about X can we talk about it
and it's it's fascinating how many
younger writers are scared to have those
conversations so you know we're we're
all encouraging them to go do that
you know there's a lot there's a lot
about it I still don't know you know if
you ask me to explain to you half the
stuff in my feature contract I would
tell you I would need to talk to my
future agent again because she explained
it all to me and I remember half of it
but a whole bunch of it I'm like oh I
don't actually remember how that bonus
gets triggered I would have to ask my
feature agent so it's a lot and it's
really important to work with people
that you feel like you can trust who are
giving you the best advice
and a younger writer would be scared to
ask or push the envelope because they
feel like I'm finally in the door I
don't want to jeopardize it that's it
absolutely like sometimes it takes so
long to get wrapped it's so hard to get
representation and they get scared of
rocking the boat because they don't want
to be without a rep
um I had a conversation with a writer
who gave me really wonderful advice and
it was that it is honestly better to be
unrepresented than to have the wrong rep
because the wrong rep is holding you
back like it sucks to not be represented
because there's stuff it's harder to
submit for you have to try to like can
your lawyer submit you if you have a
lawyer it all gets very tricky but if
you have a rep who isn't doing the work
isn't sending you out on General
meetings so that you can build a
reputation amongst Executives and
amongst producers of someone they want
to work with
they're not helping you build your
career and so it's fine to say look I
totally get that you're super busy could
you maybe put someone more Junior on my
team who can help me set up more General
meetings because I really want to
you know get to coep in the next five
years and so I need to get out there and
meet these people and be on that path
it's perfectly fine to say that because
you can frame it in a way that's not
you're not doing your job it's I totally
get that you have bigger clients than me
so would it be okay if we tried this
and if they say no they're not the right
rep for you they're just not
tips for the TV writer's room like
things that a new writer might not think
of in terms of maybe where to sit
um what if they're fidgety yes yes there
there are so many things that I feel
like I talk about in the writers room
Survival Guide that will seem silly to
people who have never worked in a
writer's room but they're so important
and so for instance
um the you know the first day you get
there and it's sort of like where does
everybody sit if it's a returning show
there are probably people who already
have seats that they like so kind of
like hang back and see what's going on
or you can say does anybody stay here
and they'll tell you if someone does or
not right
um if it's if you're the kind of writer
who is very fidgety and like you like to
draw constantly or you're like a leg
Bouncer and you need to be bouncing your
leg or you know you're you take pens
apart I've worked with writers who do
that don't sit by your show runner
because your showrunner's attention is
going to constantly be pulled to you and
that might be a problem for you so sit
across the room just sit across the room
and do your thing you got to do to feel
comfortable but it won't be right in
your showrunner's face if you are the
kind of writer who
has to go to the bathroom every hour sit
closer to the door so you can just get
up and slip out
and come back in and it won't be any big
drama because no one wants to be the
person who has to walk across the entire
writer's room every hour it's like it's
you don't nobody wants to do it so just
save yourself the problem
um you know when it comes to lunch
orders this is a big one so in a lot of
rooms the studio will provide lunch for
the writers when you're meeting in
person and there's limits to how much
you can spend and so there's usually
like a an assembly of menus of places
that you can go to right
if it's your day to pick and you don't
want to pick just pass it on just be
like I don't want to pick today someone
else pick
if it's your day to pick and you know
that the place you want to go is a place
that everybody hates please do not pick
that place
because they're all going to be mad at
you
um if you know if you notice that your
showrunner's a little grumpy today and
you know what his favorite place is pick
his favorite place
because it's like he's going to be real
happy when he's like oh we're going
there today great and suddenly his mood
gets better
um
so it's just it's a lot of silly kind of
little things but because it's a room
full of personalities that have to find
a way to coexist together those things
can be really important so I I you know
hopefully people will think about those
things when they walk in there for the
first time
are writing credits your ticket to
getting better and better work
they can be for sure
um there there are people in this
business and I will just say that who
are what we refer to as credit snobs
right so for example when I was coming
up and I had done four broadcast shows
in a row there was people at some of the
streamers and stuff who were like well
but she's only done broadcast
well then I went and did Cloak and
Dagger and I wrote a movie and suddenly
I was really cool right because I had a
cool credit and I had written a movie
and I'm like
what I did in those procedural rooms is
harder than any of the stuff that you're
like oh she's so cool for because when
you have to break a crime 16 18 22 times
with the same character solving it but
you have to find a way to make it cool
and different every week trust me that's
harder than anything you're going to ask
me to write in any of your snobby rooms
so
um that that is a thing and I will
certainly say that you know once I
transition to more streaming content and
that kind of stuff
the stuff that was offered to me
definitely changed a little bit
um so you know the fancy credits can
definitely help you get to that place
you want to go
what I always tell newer writers is you
know it used to be that you couldn't get
jobs on the fancy shows but now you can
because there's so many shows right and
they sometimes still hire staff writers
but think about your career long term so
it's great that you did a couple of
streaming shows
and you got fancy credits but you
probably didn't go to set you probably
don't barely saw any cuts of the show or
you definitely didn't get to go to post
so your career needs those skills so
that's why I tell them like if you did a
couple of fancy shows go do a season of
broadcast
and first of all you're going to make
better money because you just make
better money in broadcast and second
you're going to get a chance to do all
that stuff you didn't get to do
and people you know broadcast is its own
animal and it's a different energy and
there's something really pleasing about
breaking a story writing a story going
to see it shot and it making it on the
air in a reasonable amount of time
it's just really joyful for your friends
to not constantly be like when is your
show coming out you're like I don't know
so you know
the fancy credits will help you get some
of the cooler jobs but they will not
necessarily build the skill set that you
need to become a share Runner and run
your own show so I just tell people to
always think about that when they're
looking at the jobs that are getting
offered to them